Google’s new text to video AI has amazing
capabilities that I have not expected. It
has learned on 10 billion video tokens,
little pieces, so what did it learn?
For instance, it can create a minute-long movie
about Rookie the Raccoon, and the script for
this movie was also written by an AI. That
is excellent, but I expected that. However,
what I did not expect was this, and
this, and this. And there’s so much more.
Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Yes, it can do the usual suspects,
text to video. You provide a text
snippet, and out comes all this.
However, even in that, it can give us something
new. For instance, it can create longer videos
than most previous systems. Some of these
results can become longer than 15 seconds,
so we don’t have to splice a movie together
from these small, 4-second cuts like with many
previous techniques. Now temporal coherence is not
perfect in these cases, so the scene can change
unexpectedly over time, but it is so much better
than anything else I’ve seen so far. Great work.
But, it can do so much more. For
instance, wait, films need sounds
too, right? Can an AI help us with that?
Now hold on to your papers Fellow Scholars,
because this AI has also learned on 58 billion
audio tokens. So what did it learn? Well,
let’s listen together and take a careful look at
how good it is in making sure that the sounds line
up with the motions in the video. These were
real good, wow, what an incredible new tool!
We can also perform controllable video editing.
For instance, if we are asking for a raccoon
dancing in Times Square, we get this. Okay, but
we are experienced Fellow Scholars over here,
we ask okay, but what kind of
dancing are we talking about? And,
oh yes. We can ask it to do the robot, and
then, hmm…the dance will indeed resemble
the robot dance. Or how about this one?
Nice and fluid hip movements. Very sharp.
Now, it can also do interactive video editing.
This is amazing. First, after writing the prompt
about this rusty steampunk robot, we don’t
just have to accept this one. No sir! We
can generate several candidates, and if any
of those caught our eye, we can even extend
it. This is due to the technique’s autoregressive
nature, it sees the world as a series of tokens,
a series of numbers and characters if you will,
and thus, we can easily ask it to extend the
video with or without a prompt, thus creating
a system that is art directable! So good!
And if we can’t write a prompt for something,
because we have something really specific in mind,
just add an image. And then, look, it will make it
come alive! So that Mona Lisa can start yawning,
or that wanderer with the Klaus Kinski-like
hair can marvel at this beautiful , windy place.
And if we are happy with the idea
of the movie, but we would like
to try different stylizations of
it, we can try them immediately,
creating completely different kinds of
moods for the same, or very similar content.
And what you see here are just the trivial
cases of stylization. Now let’s bring in the big
guns. If we like these teddy bears, and have the
feeling that the floor looks beautifully glossy,
almost like ice. And then, bam! There we go.
Ice skating in a winter wonderland. Loving it.
Or if you feel like this wombat looks like
someone on the beach with a beach ball in hand,
there you go! I can only imagine what miracles you
smart and creative Fellow Scholars will be
able to do create with this in the future.
And you even get to control the camera
motions in these videos as well.
And you haven’t even heard about the
two coolest things about this work. One,
if you feel that this tool can do absolutely
everything, you are completely right. In fact,
everything is optional here.
Just chuck in whatever you want,
even a small piece of an image that you would
like to make a video of, but at the same time,
extend it via outpainting, that is also
possible. Mind-blowing. This is the full package.
And it gets better. Two, it can do all of these,
in a zero-shot manner. It can synthesize things
it hasn’t seen before. That bends the mind
a little, so a word on that. Essentially it
means that we can ask it to create something that
it does not have in its training set. However,
it can lean on its already existing knowledge
about the world. For instance, if you are
asking for a vehicle, that vehicle
should probably have a steering wheel,
or some mechanism for controlling it.
And so on. It is a bit like an actor
who can improvise a new scene when given a
description. But wait, we are still not done!
So, how quick is it? It is not in
the order of seconds per frame,
but frames per second. So we get
one second of video every 4-5
seconds. That is absolutely amazing!
I consider that to be blazing fast.
Marvelous as this paper is, of course, it is
still not perfect. There are tradeoffs to be
taken here. For instance, the resolution
of these videos is not the greatest,
something that can be remedied by current
super resolution tools, and of course, just
imagine what we will be capable of just two more
papers down the line. What a time to be alive!
And just as I finish with all this, what do I
see? Oh my. An even better video generator paper
from Google. Before you ask, of course,
we are going to talk about this one too,
soon. If you find it interesting, subscribe
and hit the bell icon to not miss out on it.